for its biggest Hardware event ever
Google went huge the tech giant ditched
the Nexus line and introduced the pixel
in its place with aluminum frames glass
backs and no camera protrusions Google's
first pixel branded phones are pretty
slick even more important though is
what's on the inside a smarter AI a
powerful processor and the best
smartphone camera ever at least
according to camera rating group DxO
mark the 5-inch pixel and the 5 and a
half inch pixel XL have identical
features including a quick charging
battery that gives them seven hours of
life after just 15 minutes of outlet
time they're available for pre-order
starting today at six hundred forty nine
dollars in the US but there's more the
pixel phones are supercharged to work
perfectly with VR
and Google now offers a new VR headset
just pop your phone in and find yourself
in another world
they're designed to fit comfortably over
glasses and you don't need any wires to
sync them with your phone Oh
in the simple daydream controller that
stores right inside the headset it'll be
available for $79 starting in November
google also announced its competitor to
Amazon echo Google home the company
spent a lot of time talking about all
the things Google assistant can do in
your home like play music from YouTube
or Spotify queue up streaming Netflix or
Hulu videos it's an answer your spoken
questions ok Google watch videos of John
Oliver on my TV the company also
trumpeted the design which is pretty
slick with a touch-sensitive panel on
top and swappable basses that come in a
selection of colors the Google home
device goes on sale for $129 today and
ships on November 4th moving on to your
TV as you'd expect the new chromecast
ultra now supports streaming videos and
4k resolution but there are a few
surprises with Google's latest dongle
and they're great the new streamer
supports both HDR 10 and Dolby vision
HDR video and there's an Ethernet port
to handle the heavier load of data
Google Play Movies will start offering
4k content next month
joining Netflix Vudu and YouTube has
supported 4k services priced at $69 the
new chromecast drops in November and if
you're worried about how your home
network can support all these devices
Google has an answer for that too
Google Wi-Fi is a new home networking
product with several access points to
blank at the home the modular and
expandable Wi-Fi hardware system lets
you add units to increase coverage
pricing was announced at $129 for a
single pack or 299 for a three pack
pre-orders start in November and the
unit ship in December the main thread
running through all of today's
announcements is the Google assistant
the voice-activated help are built into
all Android devices is the next big push
for Google and the company demonstrated
how it's applying all of its machine
learning knowledge to make the assistant
smarter and more useful we want to build
each user is sort of her own individual
rules asking details about your schedule
how to show you photos on your
chromecast ask it to read you the local
movie listings and even command it to
secure a dinner reservation at your
favorite restaurant it's also got a new
name assistant with a capital A